If I asked you to close your eyes and think about a robot,...
...maybe you envision something like this.
Maybe we wanna think about robotics from a different perspective.
Robotics is a field, really started in industrial settings,...
...where very precise and fast motion was needed.
Those same technologies are not really suitable for interacting with people.
When we think of biorobotics,...
...we really think of something that's more like the field of AI...
...of artificial intelligence.
Thinking about that combination of both the body and the brain and the group.
...there's just a lot of examples in biology...
...where we can see how that can be achieved...
...and how we can leverage the same kinds of ideas.
Almost all locomoting robots and many of the manipulator robots...
...are inspired by these soft animals that we're familiar with.
If we think of swarms in nature,...
...let's say, you think of termites that build mounds...
...or you think of ant colonies that can forage over large regions.
Imagine being able to create robotic systems that could do those tasks.